états unis à la chine en passant par
l'europe ou le mexique gants et masque
pollue ville et nature de nouveaux
déchets qui pose pas un problème
sanitaire alexis caude le monde d'après
sera-t-il plus propre qu'avant le
coronavirus masque sur les trottoirs
grands jetés à même le sol
à en croire ces images le chemin semble
encore long
depuis quelques jours les mesures de
restriction sont levés dans de nombreux
pays touchés par le coronavirus pourtant
pandémie oblige pas question de sortir
sans protection avec le déconfinement le
retour des populations dans les rues les
transports en commun les risques de
propagation se sont intensifiées masques
et gants sont désarmés indispensable
pour sortir ou bien se rendre au travail
souvent à usage unique
généralement en plastique ils se
retrouvent fréquemment jeté par terre
exposant ainsi les éboueurs à des
risques sanitaires accrus au mexique par
exemple les agents de la voirie regrette
de ne pouvoir se protéger efficacement
malgré le matériel de protection
distribué par le gouvernement et le
besoin de gagner de l'argent
les oblige à prendre des risques bien
que l'on soit conscient du danger dans
tous les cas on doit ramener quelque
chose à la maison
en fait on ne peut pas arrêter de
travailler car sinon ils imaginent et il
y aura encore plus de mal a dit il ya
des gens qui jettent les poubelles dans
les rues les avenues
ce sont des foyers d'infection et cela
va empirer oui tout ça nous fait peur on
est humain mais si on ne sort pas faire
notre travail qui va nous nourrir ils ne
nous ont rien donné
hormis des masques et des gants rien de
plus il faut bien subvenir aux besoins
de nos familles en restant à la maison
nous ne gagnons rien on ne sait pas si
les gens sont malades ou s'ils sont
porteurs du virus
mais nous devons tout de même ramasser
leurs ordures c'est notre travail
si les protections que son masques et
gants permettent de diminuer la
propagation du coït 19
il se pourrait qu'il génère d'autres
problèmes notamment celui de créer de
nouveaux foyers de contamination est
bien